would you ever tell anyone that they
weren't talented enough to do something
professionally
i would never tell someone that they're
not good enough
never because i had somebody tell me
that
in high school and
um what i have learned
working in hollywood for now is like 13
years
talent is only one piece of the puzzle
it's one piece
there are so many other qualities that
you need to succeed
outside of talent and i think that
if you care enough talent is always
something that you can work on
you know craft you get better through
practice and so you can always be in
class you can always be
working with a coach like there's so
many ways to get better in terms of your
talent
um and from a law of attraction
standpoint the law of attraction doesn't
care if you're talented or not
and i hate to say that because i don't
want to discourage people from taking
their craft seriously
but have you ever watched a tv show and
thought oh that acting wasn't very good
or that writing was oh terrible you know
or listen to a song in the radio and
thought i feel like i could sing better
than that person you know
my point is is that talent is just
one piece and to me that is not
a deterrent if you're not the most
amazing at your craft yet
i think that you can still win i think
you can still succeed
now from an integrity standpoint i think
you should be working on your craft you
know
from an integrity standpoint i think you
should care about your craft and you
should work on it and you
should practice you know i think some of
the greatest artists
in history are people that did it all
the time you know they practice all
the time so i think you should
absolutely be working on your craft
um i just think that there are so many
other qualities that you need to have
out like i talk about this in my book
where i say
you know going back to crystal even you
know if you are cold
emailing representation and you're
trying to get representation
if you email 20 people and they either
all say
no or just don't even respond
your talent is not going to get you to
keep going
it's your perseverance it's your drive
it's your desire and your ambition right
there's so many other qualities that you
need to keep going
in a moment like that so i think that
your talent
it only gets you so far and if the
talent is the only thing you have
it will most likely be a hobby and not a
career
so i i just i just will never tell
somebody that you know when it's when
someone told it to me
it's happened twice actually to me and
it was really
soul-crushing you know even in design
school
when i i tell the story it's the first
story i tell in the book
so sorry to spoil this but um
you know when i first got to art school
or the design program at the college i
was going to
i did really well on the first project
and the second project i
almost failed and the teacher said oh i
guess you just got lucky on that first
one
i will never forget that i mean i bawled
my eyes out i ran to the bathroom and
cried and i just thought wow like my
mentor this person who's supposed to
teach me how to be good
is telling me that anything i've done
well so far is chalked up to luck
and that was like so soul-crushing for
me
and then i went on to have a pretty
incredible graphic design career in one
of the hardest industries to work in in
hollywood and i've worked on over 30
television shows
so i ended up transferring schools uh
because it just it wasn't that style of
teaching wasn't for it didn't feel good
for my growth you know i didn't feel
like i was learning anything or getting
better and i just
i don't like using fear as a teaching
tactic but the point is
is that i was told that i essentially
wasn't good
and i still had an incredible dream
career
after that you know i think that i got
better i learned how to get better and
teachers told me how to get better
you know and they taught me and they
mentored me and and i got better
and plus i had all these other qualities
that go so much so far beyond talent
were they trying to use like a tough
love style of like tearing you down then
to build you back up
sort of thing was it that no it was
really you know
no because like i don't think there's
really anything wrong with tough love i
mean i guess delivery
could be debated but um tough love is
really like telling you things that you
you need you know you need to hear that
you might not want to hear
but will help for your growth and so for
me that
program was using fear as a teaching
tactic
and so like and i know that a lot of the
other students felt the same way we were
kind of scared to go to class
what is the teacher going to think what
are they going to say there's so much
fear
um you know even with that assignment
i didn't get any notes as to like what
could have been better and so i didn't
so i'm like oh i'm almost failing this
project but i don't actually
know how to make it better i just feel
bad about myself and i'm scared because
like this teacher's um you know
like instilling fear in me essentially
in the way that she
taught and she did that throughout the
whole semester so i just i didn't even
like at the end of the day i feel like i
was learning i was like
i want to be a good graphic designer but
i don't know if i'm
learning that here um
and it was interesting because almost
every student felt the same way
but i was the only one that left so
again a very teachable moment for myself
you know but
yeah i don't i don't love some people
like that teaching tactic
to use fear as a teaching tactic i i
don't for me it's not productive
i feel like i can learn how to do better
and be better without
being afraid um i feel like it doesn't
create like
or foster a safe environment to take
risks and fail
so that was my personal experience
but then how can we deliver a message to
someone without being
without protecting them too much where
they're
almost blinded because we're not giving
them the real
i don't know i mean there's like yes
people yeah a lot of times i'm sure when
people reach a certain level
they're surrounded by yes people and i
don't know if that's good or bad
probably some i don't enable them yeah
yeah i don't think that's just
surrounding yourself with yes man
i don't think is ever good at least for
growth
yeah i i think that i mean feedback it's
totally okay to give feedback you know
um that teacher was more like
you bad you know it wasn't like
constructive
feedback that i felt i could learn from
so
um you know the art school that i
transferred to was very tough
very tough um but i never felt
bad about myself i don't know it was
just constructive feedback it was like
well
this isn't working so well here but if
you do x y and z i think it would work
better and here's why
and then i would go oh that would make
this better let me do that you know then
i'm
excited about making changes because i'm
learning
why it would make it better which i
think is really important and you know
as artists
it's important to not attach
your self-worth to your work um
you know your work can be a separate
thing
um yeah what did going to that second
art school that you said was very
competitive
teach you um in terms of competition i
should question well i
i wouldn't say it was necessarily
competitive although there was
well there was a little bit of a sense
of competition they they
ranked the top five portfolios when we
graduated so
you know there was something about like
oh are you top five and and and i wasn't
in the top five but i had a professor
tell my mom oh she would have been in
the top seven if we did seven
she was in our top seven and and it's
like
like but what what does that actually
mean like i've lived such a different
career you know i went off to design
graphics for television
other people are doing other things so i
i think that
i think what it taught me is that it's
good to strive to be your best
but you don't necessarily have to strive
to be the best
because i think the best is going to be
subjective no matter
you know where you are what pool you're
in so
you know it's it's good to just strive
to be your best you know do better than
you did last time
you know see your own growth and then
let that lead to your own path you know
even looking
sometimes i would compare myself to
where my other
peers are now you know with their
careers or you know we had
a couple students from our school
one that is she graduated the year
before me i believe year or two before
me
and she became a pretty famous graphic
designer she's very well known
she's a very big following and the
teachers love that and would always
point out you know talk about her and
use her as an example of course
and then it's like oh and i'm always
trying to like we would joke about
her name in class my peers and i because
it was like oh we're never gonna live up
to
that person to our in our teacher's eyes
and
so i i guess i learned in that sense
about you know
like like stop i i want to tell myself
that even now because even now with my
book i'm like still trying to impress my
professors and i graduated like 13 years
ago and i'm still like
do they think i'm successful today like
what i'm doing
um and yeah but i think that lesson i
learned there was really like
let yourself be on your own path and you
know
just compare yourself to where you were
before and stop trying to
be or do what these other people have is
competition good in that it prepares you
for the real world because in the real
world
there's no oh you did great and oh you
get a good gold star
it's usually much more brutal than that
and it can be very cold
unfortunately yeah definitely i just
have a
slightly different belief about
competition
i believe there's room for everybody and
that might mean something different it
doesn't necessarily mean there's room
for everybody in the same exact seat
right but i do believe that we
all deserve to live our dreams in our
own way
so um it can be competitive
in the real world or even in school but
that doesn't mean that you can't live
out your dreams you know
someone beating you out for a job or an
opportunity or something
doesn't mean that you can't still live a
fulfilling life or
achieve your dreams i mean there were
jobs that i did not get you know i
interviewed
i've only interviewed like four times
maybe for a tv show most of the jobs i
got
came from connections that i built over
time
the only times that i've interviewed
i've never gotten the job
never and that didn't
mean that i couldn't still have a really
great career
i mean someone else got that job over me
right so in that sense in the
competition
i failed there or whatever someone beat
me out but there was another show for me
there were more opportunities for me you
know
so i really believe and chelsea handler
talks about this too you know she says
like there's room for everyone
can you talk about the other time that
someone said you
wouldn't be able to do something or
succeed yeah technically
they didn't say the words but it was
implied and
it was something that i'll never forget
in high school
i was very involved in
drama and chorus so i
was secretary of the drama club i was
president of the chorus
that was my life i loved singing i loved
acting
not the best at dancing but i wouldn't i
would do what was required but
that was my life you know i lived
theater
and i did pretty well
you know i was up for the lead several
times i
understudied the lead my sophomore year
i was actually up for a lead it was
between me and one other girl my
freshman year which
you know was a big deal in the politics
of high school that being a freshman up
for a lead
and um
i you know i i did well enough to be
decent you know i wasn't the star of our
high school or anything like that
i wasn't in that like top elite group
that was like really phenomenal but
i was pretty good i was good enough to
you know get a leading role
in a musical once and and some other big
parts and other opportunities
and i
loved theater i really loved acting
i was more enamored with hollywood than
broadway
but i really loved it and like i said i
did a summer program at ucla and it was
a summer theater intensive
so i actually went to ucla for acting
um when i was still in high school and
when we started applying for colleges i
didn't apply to any acting programs
and a lot of my friends did um
and i i started discovering
my love for graphic design during that
time
and so i was feeling pulled toward
graphic design and so
that was really what i was working
towards getting into for college
but i was still in the mid you know i'm
still in the midst of theater
and i sat down with my the theater
teacher one day
and it was just the two of us in a
classroom and i
looked at her and i said you know
the reason why i'm not pursuing acting
in college is because i know i'm not
good enough
and there was like that little girl
inside of me that so badly wanted her to
say
you can do it you're good enough like
give it a try if that's really what you
want to do go for it
and she did it and she just sat silent
and didn't
say anything and to me that was
confirmation you know of her saying yeah
well you're you're not the star of our
program and it's only the stars that
really go on
and you know that was so many years ago
and i
i remember that moment so clearly still
all these years later
it really had an impact on me and
it was one of the reasons you know why i
didn't pursue acting and now
you know i actually believe that
everything worked out how it was
supposed to
you know i don't still want to be an
actor even when i work with my actor
clients i have no desire i'm not
longingly looking at their careers i was
supposed to be a graphic designer that's
that became my true love um
but the lesson that i learned there that
i i wanted to i feel like
was one of the reasons i wanted to
become a coach is because i think there
are so many artists that
have those moments where they're maybe
told they're not good enough
or they think it themselves and
i said in the book that i wish the
teacher saw in me although i really need
to take full responsibility and say i
wish
i saw it in myself but i i think i wish
the teacher
saw in me that i had all these other
qualities
that could potentially lead to success
in a career
like hollywood right i was already
showing leadership skills right i was
secretary of the drama club i was
i was president over 250 person chorus
had you know worked my way up there and
so i i already had so
i was like a self-starter you know like
i had a positive outlook
i was determined and ambitious like i
had so many qualities
that could help me succeed even if i
wasn't the absolute star
you know and even if i didn't maybe get
into one of the
top desired theater programs like
there's theater programs in countries
all you earn schools all around the
country
um i don't know i i just think that you
know i i own that for myself now
that i wish i saw it in myself but i
don't think at that moment i
understood that so much more than talent
was required to succeed and now looking
at like
the people who did you know pursue
theater
in college from that program in high
school only one or two of them is
actually
doing it so um and i was still
able to create you know pretty great
career for myself in hollywood and break
in when i didn't know anybody
um and i and i didn't do that because i
was a phenomenal designer i did it
because i
had all these other qualities that
helped me break in
and we don't know someone's motives
behind why they say something too
or don't say something yeah totally i
mean you know and it could have been her
own
it doesn't really matter i think but you
know
it was just it was just a moment for me
that i i just want to help people not
feel that way because i feel like if
there's a dream in your heart
you can pursue it you know jack canfield
has this quote that i always say
where he says you wouldn't be given a
dream unless you had the capacity to
fulfill it
and i really believe that i really
believe that you wouldn't be given a
dream unless you had the capacity to
fill it
doesn't mean right in this moment when
you're 17 years old that you have all
the tools and are able to fulfill it now
right but but it creates potential like
it says that the potential is a hundred
percent
there
you